latest headlines we're getting is that
this may now extend to July ninth and
perhaps even further what are you
hearing in Vienna well that's what the
Iranian delegation has told us as of
last night they said that there are
major differences that remain between
the two sides specifically on the issue
of sanctions relief remember for the
western side of all the attention so far
for the last several months has really
been on the issue of access to verify
Iran's compliance with the nuclear deal
as well as sorting out questions about
what Iran's past military work may have
been in the nuclear sector what iran
says now is okay fine now we need equal
measures taken on our side to make sure
we're going to get sanctions relief so
Iran is saying it may take longer until
the 9th of July does the stretch into
August and dear and perhaps even into
the foal I'm sorry I couldn't hear the
question as this stretch into all this
do you think
well what we're talking about right now
at this point is that sanctions relief
has been given until the seventh the
extension of the current deal they would
have to extend it further now remember
from the US point of view they would
like to get this deal done before the
tenth of July because that's when the
corker bill kicks in when Congress would
get instead of 30 days to review the
bill they get or rather the deal they'd
get 60 days but some of the major things
that are going on between the two sides
right now are to do about the arms
embargo at the UN level which the United
States would like to keep and a number
of other elements of the sanctions
relief Iran wants their money a hundred
billion dollars in frozen assets wrote
up uploaded you know given up at the
front end